[Music]
on november 14th mr kurusu arrived in
san francisco
smiling his toothy smile as he sang the
old song of japanese
friendship the japanese were a
peace-loving people
their whole policy was devoted to the
establishment of permanent peace in asia
our aid to china foreign diplomacy is
similar to
sketching on the sand regardless of the
treaties concluded an amity established
they are completely wiped away should
the big wave of
clash of national interests wash ashore
in extreme cases doesn't the fruit of
the efforts of a predecessor end in
complete failure
because of the doing of his successors
those were the words of my son who was
killed in the last war
when he decided on a career in
engineering instead of continuing
my works now when i look back on my long
diplomatic life
these words reappear in my mind
i was about to begin writing of my
various observations and experiences
gained at my numerous posts
these were all priceless experiences but
they
in the final analysis were merely
writings
sketched in the sand i ended my
diplomatic life with the
failure of the important mission to
conclude japanese-american negotiations
in late 1941. my 35 years in diplomacy
after all were merely a bubble
it is useless to try to piece together
the pieces of broken earthenware
but i wonder whether it isn't a basic
human trait
to try anyway
it is being said that it is hardly
possible after all for an envoy
who had been hurriedly flown with such
an important responsibility at such a
critical time just
prior to the outbreak of war not to have
an accurate knowledge of what would
follow
in the event of his mission's failure
this deduction is indeed reasonable as a
conclusion reached within a country
having a
normal political structure and under
normal conditions
but no matter how i may try to deny it
it is exceedingly difficult for me to
convince others
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan have been great supporters of
content from my brother and i for a
while now
and with over 3 000 fascinating
documentaries spanning from ancient
history
all the way up to the present day they
are the perfect place to get context
for the videos on voices of the past
this week's recommendation is a great
example of that
kanji ishiwara the man who triggered the
war
the perfect companion piece to this
video it tells the story of ishiwara
and his rise in the years building up to
conflict
magellan is essentially a netflix for
documentaries with the largest range of
history stuff anywhere amongst many
other genres
so it is the perfect way to widen your
knowledge on a mountain of topics
in 2021 so click on the link in the
description for an exclusive
month-long free trial for voices of the
past viewers
[Music]
thanks
it was midnight of the 3rd of november
1941
i was fast asleep from the fatigue of
having walked at the exhibition of ueno
with my son during the day
when i was rudely awakened by the visit
of a policeman from the kojimachi
station
as our phone was out of order he had
come as an urgent messenger of the
foreign minister
to relay the message that i was wanted
immediately
at the residence of the foreign minister
on hurrying to his residence i found
foreign minister shigenori togo
vice minister haruhiko nishi kumaichi
yamamoto of the american bureau
and toshikazu casey of the first section
american bureau
all with a tense look standing in the
large drawing room on the second floor
it appeared as though they had just
concluded an important conference
on that occasion the foreign minister
first explained in general terms
the state of the japanese american
negotiation and then requested me
to go to america at this time as a
special envoy
and do my utmost in helping ambassador
kichi saburo nomura
to conclude the negotiation
now according to his explanation as
foreign minister america's attitude in
the negotiation had continued to be
unyielding
with no signs of any conciliatory
attitude furthermore since america's
economic pressure is becoming
increasingly great
our country has been placed in a
predicament wherein she must devise
some drastic measure to break the
deadlock
since the deployment of our military
strength provided for an emergency would
become known sooner rather than later
and if that should happen the japanese
american negotiation would inevitably
become much more difficult
it must be said that the situation from
an objective state
was already in a dangerous state
it is needless to say that since the
mission was of such great importance i
thought that they should have selected
the most qualified
from among the numerous experienced
elder statesmen
but the situation as explained by the
foreign minister was so pressing
that there would be no time at this late
date to look for and make overtures
to the right man and as the means of
travelling would be to fly across the
pacific
i thought it would be practically
impossible to ask of an aged
elder statesman
i decided that there was no one but
myself to do it
so i replied i'll accept it
until that evening premier tolja was a
total stranger to me
the premiere it seemed it just made
himself comfortable following a busy day
at the office
as he was in his kimono and hakama
during the course of discussion with
premier torjo that night
it was revealed the prime minister had
the same opinion as the foreign minister
and myself in recognizing this proposed
mission
to be an extremely difficult one but
given that
number one america's preparation for war
on both oceans was still insufficient
number two americans public opinion was
not supporting war
and number three americans provisions
for such important war materials as tin
and rubber were insufficient he believed
americans willfully
would not look for war he repeatedly
emphasized that i should strive for a
compromise
as he believed the possibility for
conclusion of the negotiation to be 30
percent for success
and 70 percent for failure furthermore
i still remember him saying that of the
three naughty problems of the
negotiation
the question of evacuation of troops was
one
in which no concession should be made
and that if any concession should be
made in this matter
he would not be able to face towards
yasukuni shrine
and sleep
i've ordered the california clipper a
considerably larger plane than the one
i'd been on
and headed for mainland america
i arrived in san francisco after having
slept overnight in the sleeping
compartment of the plane
as was expected of mainland america the
number of reporters and others who were
there were considerably larger
and i had great trouble in replying to
their questions
at 10 30 a.m november the 17th
accompanied by
ambassador nomura i entered the office
of the secretary of state
at the department of state and held my
first discussions
with secretary of state hull this was
not the first time i had met
secretary of state hull it was the first
time i'd met the president
[Music]
my impression of the president was what
a cheerful and broad-minded individual
he was
and that he amidst his affected heirs
possessed the appearance as to be
expected of one who came from a
blue-blooded
american family if i were to look for a
similar type among our country's
statesmen whom i know
it would be prince fumimaro conore
adorned with american-like vitality and
vigor or perhaps more accurately
if i were to say a combination of prince
konaie and lord shigenobu okuma
i explained to the president our
government's desire for peace
and sought his understanding of the
present frame of mind of our people
who had seen four years of the
sino-japanese
incident i further stated that judging
from the military situation i had seen
on my way to america
even i a layman in military matters
could see the situation was very
pressing
and in such a state as would explode
into crisis should one full step be made
i asked what would japan and america
gain by bringing about such a situation
the president expressing a similar
opinion promptly replied
yes what for i continued and explained
that what we should note at this time
was the question of time
element and should the negotiation be
prolonged any longer japan's position
would become
graver both economically and militarily
eventually leading to her total
submission in reply to this the
president
quoted the famous remark there are no
last words
between friends he thus made it clear
that america had the intention to
continue the negotiation
to the very end
i suggested that even in regard to the
sino-japanese peace question
as long as america interferes even in
setting terms and
manifests such attitude as to support
china it would be very difficult
to reach a conciliation between japan
and china
the president replied that he had heard
of the difficulty of evacuating the
troops because of the sino-japanese
question
and he stated i don't know whether such
a word as this is used diplomatically
but how would it be if america were to
be the introducer
for both japan and china
i strove very hard to induce a speedy
conclusion of the negotiation
by impressing strongly upon america the
urgency of the situation and at the same
time was very careful in the usage of my
words to avoid giving either party a
feeling of
intimidation however my hope for the
future of the negotiation was
strengthened
because of the statesmanlike attitude of
the president the proposal for general
agreement
and the use of a word such as introducer
however the reply which we received from
our government
was a very furious one almost a
reprimand
it read the pressing situation of today
absolutely cannot be saved with merely
such a guarantee as to restore the
situation to that which existed prior to
the freezing
of funds it censored us for having
presented our plan without prior
arrangements as regrettable in view of
the delicate domestic situation
and directed us to submit without fail
plan b
at our next meeting stating so long as
america's acceptance of the above cannot
be had
it cannot be helped should the
negotiation
be ruptured on the 20th of november
plan b was submitted the primary reasons
why america refused to give her consent
to plan b
were as follows discontinuation of aid
to chiang kai-shek
is tantamount to discontinuation of aid
to great britain
america cannot accept it the transfer of
troops in southern french indochina
mainly to the north would still keep the
troops of other nations
in the southwest pacific area the
statements of important government
leaders as usual
advocate the armed aggrandization policy
there is none such as would give
credence to this peaceful intention of
japan
and finally the fact that japan's
furious request for a reply without
consideration of the fact that each of
the nations concerned must request their
respective government for instructions
gave the impression as though it were a
demand
secretary of state hull's attitude which
had been friendly and cheerful until the
conference of the 26th of november
appeared to have changed suddenly i came
to think of it later
but it was because of an important
reason dispatch number 726 from togo to
nomura
was sent on the day of my departure the
5th of november
this was one of the reasons for the
misunderstanding that i had come to
america with the knowledge that a final
ultimatum
would be submitted that this message had
been intercepted by america has been
explained at the beginning of this book
furthermore
this message had been completely
mistranslated
and it appears as if the translation was
completed and shown to the secretary of
state
on about the 22nd the message in
question was the instruction from tokyo
concerning
plan a which is one of our final plans
although the original message had as its
beginning the phrase
as a final conciliatory plan america's
intercepted message
read as a final revised ultimatum
it is only logical that america
including secretary of state hull
became offended upon reading this
mistranslation and reached the
conclusion
that japan possessed no sincerity
our meeting with the president was held
on the 27th of november
amidst such an oppressive atmosphere the
previous meeting that is the meeting of
the 17th was held in the official
reception room of the white house
but this was held in a room appearing to
be the office of the president
of course the secretary of state was
present the situation then was not only
pressing for me
according to the literature made public
since the end of the war the president
too appeared to have been fully
cognizant of the seriousness
of the situation in spite of this
the attitude of the president towards us
was suave and graceful
and cheerful after we had taken our
seats and ambassador nomura had accepted
a cigarette offered by the president
the president personally lit a match and
attempted to light the cigarette
but ambassador nomura having only one
good eye
could not bring the point of his
cigarette to the light extended by the
president
the president laughed and extended his
hand further to light the cigarette
consequently the meeting was begun
ostensibly in an extremely amicable
atmosphere
the president then pointed out that
japan and america had suffered together
as allies during the last war because
germany was not able to understand the
psychology
of the other nations continuing further
he explained that he was happy to hear
that there have been some peace
advocates in japan
and that he still had great hopes of
japan and america arriving at a peaceful
settlement
in all probability the president must
have been receiving in rapid succession
from the american authorities stationed
along the coast of french indochina and
china
reports of the movement of our land and
sea forces the unloading of various
weapons
and the movements of our transports the
situation wherein the negotiation would
become much more difficult as the
deployment of our strength became known
was gradually becoming a reality just as
foreign minister togo
had feared the time of my departure from
tokyo
the president further explained that as
stated by envoy kurusu recently
he was fully aware that the frame of
mind of the japanese people
who had suffered four years of war could
not be measured by the standard of
peaceful america but the fact that there
had been no peaceful statements from the
leaders of japan during the discussions
between the secretary and state and us
had made this negotiation very difficult
finally the conference ended with
ambassador nomura
relying on his friendship of 30 years
with the president appealing to him
to break the deadlock with his statement
in other words with this discussion
our effort to make america reconsider
and bring about a change in the deadlock
ended in a complete failure
the negotiation was now in a practically
hopeless
situation
the secretary of state who had been
silent to the newspapers and others
concerning the negotiation in the past
voluntarily made a public statement
concerning the meeting
on the 26th responding to this the
newspapers
with such headlines as hull hands peace
plan to japan and
america rejects second munich plan
emphasized such points of
secretary of state hull's so-called four
basic principles
against which no one could raise an
objection as abstract arguments and
wrote that it was up to japan
whether to accept america's proposal the
japanese government's dispatch explained
that it regarded america's note of the
26th
as surprising and regrettable and
instructed us that japan
absolutely cannot consider this note as
an overture and that there was no
alternative
but to submit to them the imperial
government's opinion
to be wired in two or three days and in
reality
to break off the negotiation
however just before this premier tojo's
american and british expulsion speech
was greatly played up in the american
newspapers on the 30th
of november above all the part claiming
the british
and american exploitation of the asiatic
races
should be exterminated with vengeance
was given larger publicity
since the prime minister had clamored
for the expulsion of the opposing
country in which not one but two
of these ambassadors were busily engaged
in a negotiation
it was not unreasonable for the
repercussion it caused within the
various quarters of america
to have been so strong as to be beyond
the imagination
of people in japan
the first of december meeting with the
secretary of state was held at the
department of state under such an
extremely
tense atmosphere at the very outset the
secretary of state touched upon the
premier's speech
with a grave expression i explained that
i believe the premier speech probably
had been twisted and exaggerated stating
that
if only a certain portion and not the
complete text of anyone's speech is
given the real intention of the talker
could be misinterpreted into something
with an entirely different meaning
then the secretary of state revealed
that he was receiving in rapid
succession from the american authorities
on the spot reports concerning the
latest deployment of our troops
in the southwest pacific area he
explained that we would be able to fully
understand how america felt today if our
positions were reversed
and the japanese army and navy were
placed in a similar position
as the close of the meeting i stated
that the motto don't sell china down the
river
was prevalent in america but would not
japan and america be selling themselves
down the river
if they should eventually go to war
against each other because of the china
question in reply the secretary of state
nodded
but only repeated that in view of the
present situation
he wanted japan to open the way for
fresh development
through the improvement of her speeches
under secretary of state sumner wells
who substituted for secretary of state
hull
who was ill requested us to call he
handed us a document stating that it was
from the direct order
of the president it pertained to the
recent strengthening of our troops
in the southern french indochina area it
was a harsh document of warning
announcing beforehand
that appropriate actions would be taken
in terms of america's
national defence depending on japan's
reply
the document received from the under
secretary was immediately wired to our
government
but our government's reply was very
brusque
it stated that the rumor of the
strengthening of our troops was
considered to be an exaggerated report
of the strengthening of our troops in a
section of northern french indochina
initiated primarily for the purpose of
preparing against the chinese troops
recently active along the border as we
saw it when compared with the reports
believed to be in the hands of america
then
this response will hardly be
satisfactory to them
at the same time the department of state
issued a report that there were 125 000
japanese troops in french indochina in
two divisions under the escort of
warships
appeared to have finally become critical
consequently we who were unaware that
the government had held an imperial
conference
and had already decided on the war were
deeply concerned about the situation and
requested the government to give us a
reply clarifying our peaceful
intentions a little more if it desired a
settlement of the negotiation
however our government's reply was that
it was impossible to explain any further
since it involved the secret
the 7th of december was sunday i heard
from naval attache ichiro yokoyama who
had called in the morning that many
messages seemed to have been delivered
to the embassy office
then i received a report from secretary
yuki that the imperial government's
opinion
mentioned in the government's
instructions of the 28th of november
had arrived since numerous messages had
arrived simultaneously that morning
there appeared to have been considerable
confusion in the embassy office in the
wireless room
the final message specifying the time
for the handing over of the memorandum
arrived about 10 30 am of the seventh
and since
instructions to the effect that typists
should not be permitted to type the
memorandum for the preservation of its
secrecy
a higher grade secretary who was not
adept at typing
began typing it from the morning of the
seventh it did not progress as quickly
as expected
ambassador nomura too was considerably
worried
and it became evident that the important
memorandum would not be ready for 1pm
the time arranged with secretary of
state hull the appointment was
unavoidably put off
until 2pm i together with ambassador
nomura went to the state department
it was 2 20 p.m when we finally met with
the secretary of state
after looking at the clock in the room
and announcing the time to us the
secretary of state began reading the
memorandum which was handed to him
in the meantime the excitement gradually
caused his hand holding the memorandum
to begin
shaking finally after having finished
reading it
the secretary of state made the now
historically famous remark
throughout the nine months of
negotiation i never did say a lie
and in my 50 years of public service i
have never seen a document so
full of fabrication and falsehood
after we had heard this we silently left
the secretary's office
as this was sunday and the meeting had
been arranged suddenly that morning
there were not many people at the
department of state and practically no
reporters when we arrived there
when we were about to leave they began
gathering gradually but we refrained
from replying to their inquiries and
returned to the embassy
it was then that we heard the news of
the attack on
pearl harbor as soon as the automobile
we were riding entered
the front gate of the embassy was closed
and the police
started warding off the crowd which
began together
when i entered my room upon returning to
the embassy i saw finance officer
tsutomu nishiyama
standing dumbfounded as he was an expert
on finance and economics and had been
residing in and studying in america for
many years
he knew better than anyone else that
japan absolutely would be no match for
america
in protracted war with a feeling that we
lacked the one thing we needed we
blankly stared at each other
i could think of nothing to say
in the meantime military attaches saburo
soda
with tears in his eyes came to my room
and expressed his sympathies
the other members of the embassy all had
a dejected look
i certainly was deeply moved by the
varied feeling of sympathy shown by
these people
toward me who had failed in an important
mission
[Music]
you